[Musique]
bonsoir mes petits amis
mais qu'est ce que tu as à renifler
ainsi nounours le pusher dole pas trop
si tu te frottes l'oeil ça va te faire
mal nounours ça fait déjà mal portants
je souffre au l'on prend ton échelle et
va rendre visite à nicolas et
pimprenelle sommes froid du dieu je
souffrirais moins bon lol mon dieu
patron j'en vois deux voyants nounours
tu n'en as kind échelle ce vrai patron
c'est sûrement cette douceur dans l'oeil
tu me fais des plaques cicala bien tracé
maman mais tu sais patronne elle si tu
mets mon masque et moi ne tient ce sera
bien plus drôle et pourquoi nicolas
c'est parce que nous nous ne pourra pas
notre but c'est vrai on accorde encore
une meilleurs hits et ouais ok si on y
arrive
boussois besson font ma parole je vois
réellement double je vois de nicolas mas
à vannes vous poussez coup ça mon petit
nicolas mais oui dont sa petite soeur
patronat
après au ma petite pas preneur sayah je
vois deux nouveaux doubles je vois deux
papes rhonelle pauvre nounours d'abord
choix de nicolas puis ensuite deux
pimprenelles approche toi que je te vois
de plus près à cette fois il n'y a
qu'une pape rhône elle tant mieux j'ai
poussé heures d'horloge mais ça va mieux
qu'est ce que tu as mal aux yeux le nose
mais je portais des lunettes
mais voyons nicolas pourquoi mais tu la
chemise de ta soeur un garçon ça porte
un pyjama ça recommence de nicolas et se
continue 2 pas preneur oh là là et de
nicolas ouhlala ah les petits coquins ya
un vrai débat ce détournement et je me
suis dit c'est quand même pas mal à m'y
attendais tajo j'attrape au dodo uss
[Musique]
oh
ans
south hall ont dormi vite petit diable
de nicolas mes petits amis
il est l'heure de faire comme nicolas et
pimprenelle et d'aller vite au lit à te
voilà nounours
comment se porte on est un peu mieux
merci patron mais à présent j'ai mal à
la tête
ces deux petits brigands branco refait
blog que je sais north mais elle était
bien innocente mais je marche à chaque
coup pas trop je suis trop pinault son
oie à alan en route gros innocent
bonne nuit les petits si vous êtes très
sage
nous vous ferons demain une très très
grosse surprise
or ça oui ils vont être bien et onu à
demain
faites de pour eux
[Musique]
oh